uh we're going to start with what is
webassembly because I think that's a
decent question to start with we'll talk
about the history we'll say no but
really what is webassembly we'll talk
about using webassembly and node.js
we'll talk about why you'd use
webassembly and we'll talk about what's
next
so what is webassembly it's complicated
let's break it down
first of all webassembly the technology
and this will be important webassembly
the technology allows us to compile
other languages down into bytecode that
runs in near native performance in
webassembly run times
this might sound vague it's going to get
less vague I promise
the thing about webassembly is it is
neither web strictly nor is it assembly
so
so stop doing that
um anyways uh webassembly isn't strictly
web because there are run times that do
not run in browsers or in node there are
runtimes for iot devices there are
runtimes for all sorts of different
platforms so it's not strictly web-based
and it's not assembly because assembly
by definition is something that targets
a certain chipset and webassembly does
not Target a certain chipset it targets
a certain runtime but it is very
assembly-esque and I'll show you what I
mean by that with an example here in a
bit but first let's talk about like the
history because
um
it's kind of interesting and a little
important so pre-2015 we had NaCl and
asm.js and we were starting to like work
our way towards uh containable code and
safe code things like that and NaCl was
not meant to be in open source all the
way project so that was interesting and
then asmjs also just used a subset of JS
so the performance was a little not as
much as they wanted it so in 2015 the
web assembly working group estab was
established with the cooperation of
major browser vendors and a few other
large companies
by 2017 we had support in all major
browsers and that still continues to
this day in 2017-ish it was kind of hard
to actually pin down a date but support
dropped in node.js in 857.
in 2018 the w3c published the first
working drafts for the webassembly
working group
in 2019 Wazi which we'll go over in a
bit was announced by Mozilla and in
November 2019 the bytecode alliance
which is a group that oversees the Wazi
project was founded
no but what is webassembly really you
gave me this real vague definition cast
can you can you kind of go over it a
little more for me
so webassembly itself is kind of a
loaded term because we use the term to
talk about the technology but we also
use the term to talk about the
specification for the byte code so to uh
kind of undo any uh confusion I'm going
to say webassembly when I mean the
technology and I'm going to say wasm
when I'm talking about the specification
for the byte code hopefully that clears
some things up
there's also an acronym salad to get
through so let's get started there will
be a quiz not no there's not actually
going to be a
vehicle
um so was them is short for webassembly
and that's why I kind of use it to help
with the overloaded terms what is human
readable webassembly text format and
this is what looks a lot like assembly
when you look at it is what
then you've also got Wuzzy which is the
webassembly system interface and and
this allows webassembly to make calls
outside of the webassembly code itself
like being able to communicate with a
file system Network calls things like
that
so this is an example of what this would
print console.log hi
it does look quite a bit like assembly
in that you've got you know
um
very
succinct instructions very basic
instructions kind of line up one by one
um you've got you've got memory buffers
you have to pass the offsets there's
very little memory management there is
no garbage collection in webassembly yet
so yeah it's very webassem or
assembly-esque that was a lot of slides
there we go
so let's talk a little bit more about
Wazee because I mentioned what it is but
why is important is um a little
different wasm makes the code portable
right when we compile down to wasm we
have byte code that can run in any
webassembly runtime Wazi makes
applications portable it's the interface
surrounding it like I said that allows
you to go to file system Network calls
all sorts of different calls that you
would not necessarily be able to access
with just webassembly straight up things
like even console.log running the most
basic hello world in the web is not
doable with just wasm you need Wazi on
top of that to declare what console.log
actually is it's very similar I like to
compare Wazi to like the standard i o
libraries for C or posix libraries for C
where like those are implemented on all
the different chipsets so you can move
your C code everywhere you want submit
the similar thing with webassembly
you've got the runtime and Wazi which
are implemented for every single set up
and then you've got the code which is
moved across each platform
so we'll talk a little bit about how
this works in terms of how we use it
what you do is you'll first write code
in rust or C plus plus we're going to do
Rust today very simple rest program uh
then you compile that to wasm
then you load that wasm into a runtime
using JS for now there's some runtimes
that are kind of wanting to go away
which is fine but in this case we'll use
node and we'll use a wasi implementation
so that we can write to console.log and
write to file system from webassembly
and then you run your exported functions
from JS much like you would a JavaScript
module it will export functions and you
can run those functions in webassembly
from JavaScript
so I'm going to talk about using it with
node
what we're going to do is we're going to
write rust code that well we're going to
View Rest code I did not sleep well last
night so I'm not going to try to Live
code
we're going to print string hello world
to standard out and to a file
we're going to compile the rust code
using Wazi into wasm sorry there's just
so many acronyms and then node.js code
will use the experimental Wazi module to
load and run our wasm
I'm surprised I got through that in one
go
so let's go into the demo I'm gonna get
out of my slides and I'm gonna go over
to my
oh I closed my code editor nice
it worked awesome all right the demo
commence all right so what I've got here
is I've got a Wasa module folder and um
that is where my rust code lives
and then I have a basic node.js
application with run wasmjs and then
I've moved wasm Dash module.wasm yeah my
naming could use a little work there
um out into the main folder so that's
easily accessible by the JavaScript so
let's take a look at the rust code
um I got this from the uh one of the
wasm example sites um it was less about
what the rust could do and where about
like getting this demo working so we
have um we're calling an f file system
we're printing hello world to
standard.out and then we're saying
create a file at hello world hello
world.txt
and then we're writing hello world file
[Music]
so
um next we'll look at
the JavaScript code
okay so in uh this we are pulling out
read file because we need to read the
wasm file in order to execute it uh
we're pulling in Wazee so that we can
tell our webassembly here's how here's
here's a console.log function here's a
file uh Handler function our file writer
function
um yeah and so when we instantiate Wazi
what we do is we pass anything we want
to pass to the wasm from node uh in
through these parameters so we've got
arguments we've got environment and
we've got what we're just called
pre-opens and what this means is I'm
giving Wazi permission to access this
part of my file system so
um you have to tell it I'm so when it
writes tries to write to hello world
it's going to write to this directory
that we're sitting in
finally you import Wazi
um it is still definitely experimental
in node so we'll have to use a command
line function as well a command line
argument as well uh to get this to run
but once we do we'll compile the
webassembly or read from our wasm file
and then we'll instantiate the
webassembly code once it's been compiled
and then we'll start it so let's get
this running
[Music]
so first thing I'm going to do is let's
pretend I just wrote my
um rust code here so I'm going to
CD was a module now I'm going to say
cargo build
are you kidding me
all right that's fine that's fine we can
figure this out luckily I wrote myself a
readme
always write yourself or read me
copy so the reason I'm doing this is I
need to tell cargo to compile the rust
to web a web assembly 32-bit with Wazee
uh available and that I want it to be in
the release folder and so I'm going to
do that I'm just gonna
paste this
all right so
um that was fast oh because uh I already
built it and it's just kind of sitting
there
so that about uh CP the file back out
into the root but since it didn't change
I'm not actually going to copy that
particular column and then I'm going to
CD out into the root folder ALS
you can see uh was a module.wasm
and then we are going to
you're going to go back to the readme
because like I said when we run it with
node experimental as you can see here
I've got this flag experimental Wazi
unstable preview one that is how we tell
node yes I want to use Wazi please let
me
[Music]
so there we go
fantastic all right so um yay we've got
hello world and standard out and uh
we've got in our folder now a hello
world.txt with Hello World on it and
that's done in Russ so
um no it's so uh node.js loaded the rust
code but the rust code actually ran via
wasn't byte code to complete these steps
so
now that we've done the demo
foreign
so why would you use webassembly
one of the first things that people tend
to think of is if you need to do
something that node.js or JS isn't
necessarily good at
um heavy computation
machine learning JavaScript is good at
machine learning but if you've net if
you want to run it in a different
language that's fine too another great
thing is not compiling native modules
anymore who here would never like to
compile another made of module again
yeah I could tell I could tell the
contributors because they went
um yeah the idea is instead of compiling
a native module every time you npm
install you would ship wasm code that
would run in node without any other
alter uh alterations so you could do c
libraries rust libraries
um name a language it probably has at
least an experimental wasm compiler so
it's kind of an interesting use case the
other thing is I was I was really
interested in the last talk about
sandboxing environments there are
actually server list providers who use
wasm as a Sandbox to run user code
instead of just you know running on a
container it's container list which is
really nice for performance so yeah
that's another situation
so what's next
I hesitate to say this webassembly is in
kind of a lull right now a lot of
proposals are still kind of staying
there but the outside of the proposal
Arena and the the working group Arena
companies are jumping on this um
webassembly is becoming more and more
popular like I said containerless
infrastructure seems to be like the new
like
the new shiny thing to do with
webassembly is to create your own
containerless infrastructure where you
can just run user code and it's
sandboxed and it's safe and it can only
do what you tell it it can do
um the good news is uh one thing that
happened in the
um byte code Alliance is wasometime 1.0
which is their dedicated wasm runtime
shipped to 1.0 so they have declared it
production ready so if you're wondering
is webassembly production ready yeah at
least wasn't time is
so and there are a lot of proposals
still in Flight
um garbage collection
yep they know they're working on it
garbage collection's hard but uh it's
there's definitely still work to be done
and work that is being done it just kind
of feels like a lull at this point and I
feel like it's it we're pushing through
and we just need to get through it well
by we I mean the folks at the bite code
Alliance and W and w3c working group I'm
not actually a member I'm just a fan
well anyway